you were just on a nice vacation yes
where'd you go in the Caribbean what's
the Caribbean I love the Caribbean yeah
we were on a catamaran it was the waters
beautiful and it's great did you go like
one of my favorite things is snorkeling
I love snorkeling did you do that I did
yeah I don't like it I mean I don't like
snorkeling everybody likes snorkeling
well not everybody yeah okay all right
hate it so much
yeah what what is that what do you
always get scared it's not my world
under there and and then I'm afraid I
don't not my world it's not what what's
the Caribbean so like you drove into a
bad neighborhood it's that it's like
beautiful what you know water no I'm
saying the beautiful water and the fish
but that's not for me
yeah I don't belong there or I could
breathe and live yeah there and I can't
I hate it so much so everyone's jumping
and my husband is sister my son
everyone's jumping in and they're
swimming and swimming and I'm trying to
catch up and I'm think I'm getting tired
and now there's water coming into the
snorkel and I thought well I'm gonna
drown and I just go back like just
hightail it out of there so you get out
of there you don't everyone comes back
on like oh did you see the blue fish and
there was a yellow fish like yeah I saw
okay who cares you don't know it love oh
I'd love a few had a travel show would
you love that it Lisa that's such a good
idea for you and Lisa Kudrow hosted a
crab
but you were just like yeah you're just
like I'm inside this nice room and
there's a window and there might be some
foxes out there but I don't want to get
involved I would do it your hope don't
do it
what about what about scuba diving would
you ever do that never ever unnecessary
risk
i I mean if it's like oh it's great and
you just make sure that you know you
don't go faster than the smallest bubble
well how do you know which one's the
smallest bubble I mean the smallest
bubble I see and then there might be a
smaller one that's right slower and
dependent when you're coming up to the
surface you can't always yeah severe
neurological problem there is no joy of
exploration you have none of that no
[Laughter]
experience I'm looking to have yeah yeah
so like it's so camping you wouldn't
like camping and then like going in the
woods and oh look there's a baby cub you
know I think nothing to do with that no
we're so different that way I want to
fight a bear I saw I do I wanna I want a
bear and I to be circling each other you
know I want that kind of thing oh man
makes you feel alive I'm a real
daredevil I'm a real man's fee and
that's what I need to do this know my
husband went night scuba diving your
kits wait so you won't even go scuba
diving you let him go night scuba diving
let him what do you mean his mommy
no I guess your marriage works
differently than mine
you're not going anywhere there's not a
perfect impression of my wife I thought
she was here
you